[Musique]
aujourd'hui je vais vous parler de
google qui a excusé moi je n'avais pas
conduis moi de moi je vois google qui a
officialisé le dos de son pixels 4 qui
sera présenté au mois d'octobre de cette
même année en octobre 2019
parce qu'effectivement google et ses
mauvais sur la gestion des fuites est
justement ce lundi matin pour couper
court à tout ça on va balancer
directement une photo en tout cas rendu
de ce que va être notre pixels car ce
qui est super intéressant sur ce rendu
ces convois qui aura un espèce de gros
pavés en haut à gauche de l'appareil
avec plusieurs modules photo a priori
trois modules photo cc spectre du groupe
ab c'est ce qu'on retrouve notamment
dans les rumeurs sur le prochain iphone
donc ça c'est maman qui le positionnent
comme ça personnellement je suis pas
hyper fan de ce que j'ai pu voir en tout
cas sur les rumeurs de l'iphone si
effectivement apple nous fait ça un peu
dubitatif
lorsque j'ai vu sur la copie de google
sont pas trop mal mais c'est pareil faut
par une fois qu'on a le smartphone dans
les mains parce que ça fait quand même
espèce de groupe avec déséquilibrer son
côté c'est assez bizarre pour justement
leur parlons de ce pic 7,4 forcément
vous n'avez pas pu louper que l'année
dernière google a sorti son pixels 3
pixels 3xl là ya pas longtemps le qui
cède 3 à peach et 3xl dans le milieu de
gamme et avec son pixels trois pales
paltrow a mis deux trois un peu
compliqué à force le pixel 3 mpix et 3
xl google est vraiment rentré au top du
des photophones c'est vraiment je dirais
un des meilleur photophone si ce n'est
le meilleur
avec un seul capteur photo là ils vont
nous mettre trois capteurs photos dont
je pense cette fois ci ils vont mettre
la barre encore plus haut pourquoi est
ce que google est juste e-performance
donnellan a tout simplement parce que
ils ont effectivement une partie
matérielle qui est plutôt honnête plutôt
bien fait mais surtout derrière ils ont
une armée d'ingénieurs qui vous sortent
des algorithmes incroyable qu'on
traitement photographique donc si vous
avez du bon hardware donc en matériel de
bonne qualité et derrière une armée
d'ingénieurs qui vous optimiste où ça
nous avons rendu qui est assez
exceptionnel mais c'est vraiment toute
la france en tout cas de ce pixel 3 et
le pixel 4 je suis arrivé il y en a
tellement de civils militaires et deux
pick ce cadre devrait être encore au
dessus on sait pas effectivement qu'elle
vaut et de ses capteurs
on a effectivement je pense à capteur
principal 12 13 mégapixels comme ce
qu'on est sûr de pixels 3 un deuxième
capteur alors est ce que ça sera un
téléobjectif
x 500 prend effectivement ça reste un
petit peu compliqué à avoir mais a
priori sur le troisième capteurs on
aurait une caméra tough c'est la caméra
time of light qui est là en fait pour
mesurer la profondeur qui permettrait
encore plus loin avec le mode portrait
pour les faits évoqués et aussi pour pas
mal d'applications réalité augmentée
donc ça pourrait être assez intéressant
on va essayer de voir un petit post
comment va se positionner google
justement par rapport à 100 en termes de
stratégie est ce qu'ils vont se
positionner sur de la réalité augmentée
avec ce smartphone oui non pas comment
en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est qu'on
aura des photos de bien meilleure
qualité toujours plus loin avec ce tir
est je pense un mode portrait encore
plus optimisée à bord après le rendu est
ce que ce sera effectivement un
téléobjectif est ce que ce sera une
caméra grand angle ça on va lui en tout
cas ce qui est intéressant et si on
regarde aussi le dos de ce smartphone
si vous voyez qu'il n'ya pas du tout de
capteur d'empreintes digitales oddo a
est ce qu'on aura un capteur intégré
sous l'écran ce qui paraît en tout cas
et dans le sens de l'évolution de ce
qu'on trouve en tout cas en 2019 sur les
smartphones ça me semblerait logique que
google nous mettre ça un capteur sous
l'écran hyper optimisé on aura
probablement à un fax unlock mais bon ça
là dessus il ya rien rien de surprenant
en soi c'est très drôle de voir la
manière dont google comme une exception
de parler on coupe court à tout le monde
on balance on met un rendu du dos comme
ça au moins ça traîne un peu tout le
monde sait calmer un peu les ardeurs et
puis on redonne un petit peu comme ça au
fur et à mesure alors on en reparlera
plus tard ça au mois d'octobre on va
aller voir google on verra lors de l'
annonce comme ça je vous en reparle et
vous invite dès maintenant à vous
abonner comme ça vous saurez tout ce qui
est très drôle c'est de voir l'évolution
du marché le ce marché le marché de ce
marché le marché du smartphone est de
plus en plus difficiles il ya un taux de
renouvellement qui va même un peu plus
bas
c'est vrai j'ai changé un peu l'année
prochaine avec notamment l'arrivée de la
5g on imagine que pour que le
consommateur et des smartphones 5g
compatibles entre 2020 et 2025 à eibar
plus de renouvellement pour aller encore
plus vite sur les autres 5 dès que les
opérateurs
ça peut être assez intéressant ça on le
verra également l'année prochaine mais
en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il
ya un vrai bousculement il ya une montée
en puissance des acteurs chinois en
europe on va que samsung conserve
toujours sa place de leader même si
effectivement ils perdent quand même en
nombre de ventes c'est quand même
beaucoup beaucoup moins bon huawei a
explosé à plus de 66% progression au
premier semestre
au premier trimestre 2010 9 en europe
c'est assez énorme
apple a régressé et passer en troisième
position derrière vous avez shiomi qui a
monté ça c'est marrant de voir
effectivement si l'explosion de chat ou
mika
il pas un petit peu par rapport à à
nokia fasse un truc est assez fou on se
retrouve donc avec samsung huawei apple
et shiomi
quelle place occupe google la dent je
pense qu'ils sont vraiment dans les pas
énormément de ventes 1 par rapport aux
pixels 3 et parapente sel 3 à 2 cette
année aussi donc à mon avis avoir
effectivement se donner avec ce pis
elles quatre ces permettra à google
d'aller conquérir plus de parts de
marché d'aller progresser sur ce segment
là à voir en tout cas tout ça on en
reparle
une petite brève un peu d'actu comme ça
je vous raconte aussi un petit peu
l'actu des mac gorain fait ce qui se
passe j'ai pas vous comment vous le
trouvez vous le rendu de ce dos de ce 4
intéressant oui non est-ce que vous avez
surtout ce gros carrés en haut à gauche
est ce que vous trouvez ça bien intégrés
et à votre avis marquer le moindre
commentaire à votre avis qu'est-ce qu'on
aura comme capteur photo caméra
principale sans eau sans doute grande
télé photo caméra tough vous marier tout
ça et je donne rendez vous dès demain
voilà je vais parler de teck vous
embrasse